ALL THE REACTION.
ALL ON F BE AND THE.
SEE YOU THEN.
>> Dana: LIVE FROM
WASHINGTON, D.C., I AM
DANA PERINO WITH
KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE,
JUAN WILLIAMS, JESSE WATTERS AND
GREG GUTFELD.
AND THIS IS SPEETHIRTY.
FOUR HOURS AWAY FROM THE STATE
OF THE EVENING ADDRESS LIVE AT
9:00 P.M. EASTERN.
THE BELLS ARE RINGING.
IT'S AMAZING.
GREG GUTFELD IS SINGING.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ADDRESSED A
WE ARE EXPECTED TO GET EXCERPTS
WHEN THEY COME IN.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS THE TONE OF
THE SPEECH WILL BE BRIGHT AND
OPTIMISTIC.
THE PRESIDENT SPEAKING ABOUT
IT HAS BEEN A CONTENTIOUS YEAR
BETWEEN REPUBLICANS DEMOCRATS
LET'S GO TO GREG.
>> Greg: TWO OBSERVATIONS.
HE'S GOING TO DO A GREAT JOB
BECAUSE THE EXPECTATIONS ARE SET
THEY EXPECT SO LITTLE FROM HIM
THAT ALL HE WILL HAVE TO DO IS
JUST THE --
>> Dana: I THINK EXPECTATIONS
ARE HIGH THIS TIME.
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK SO IT
ALL.
PEOPLE ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO
THEM BEING EVIL AND WRONG
COMMAND HE WILL BE NICE.
FERGUSON FROM "THE WEEKLY
STANDARD."
IT WOULD BE MUCH BETTER IF HE
GOT THERE AND SAID YOU DON'T
NEED THIS.
I TWEET EVERY DAY.
YOU DON'T NEED THE STATE OF THE
UNION.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS FOLLOW ME
ON TWITTER.
I TELL YOU EVERYTHING THAT'S ON
MY MIND.
THIS IS THE FIRST AND LAST STATE
OF THE UNION I'M EVER GOING TO
THOSE BONUSES.
I'M GOING HOME.
THAT WOULD BE THE MOST AWESOME
STATE OF THE UNION OF ALL TIME.
>> Dana: HE MIGHT GET A
STANDING OVATION.
>> Greg: THE PROBLEM IS IT IS
SO FAKE.
THE REASON WHY THE STATE OF THE
UNION SUCKS IS THAT IT IS SO
FAKE.
STANDING UP, SITTING DOWN.
IT IS SO CHOREOGRAPHED,
LIKE A LOT OF THINGS.
>> Dana: I AM ONE OF THE
SHORTEST PEOPLE EVER ON THE
>> Dana: THEY GAVE ME A CHOICE
BETWEEN A PILLOW AND A HEATED
SEATS.
I CHOSE THE HEATED SEAT.
ARE YOU EXCITED FOR TONIGHT?
BADER GINSBURG FALL ASLEEP.
>> Jesse: DARN IT.
SOMEONE IS GOING TO FALL ASLEEP
AND EMBARRASS THEMSELVES.
AT ONE POINT THE CAMERA WILL GO
TO VERY OLD SENATOR AND THAT
SENATOR WILL BE DOZING OFF AND
THOSE OF THE BEST MOMENTS.
INTERESTING TO SEE PEOPLE BRING
RETURNS OF THE DEMOCRATS ARE
BRINGING ILLEGAL ALIENS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE SAYING THEY
SHOULD BRING I.C.E. AGENTS.
ROUND THEM UP RIGHT THERE.
CONNECTING WITH MAINSTREAM
TELEPROMPTER.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO SUPPORT
PRESIDENT TRUMP LOVE
TELEPROMPTER TRUMP.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHEN HE IS ON
A LONG TIME, JUAN.
LOOKING FORWARD TO THE NEXT YEAR
AND LOOK AT IMMIGRATION AND
>> Juan: I AM OVERWHELMED BY
THE WINNING.
SO MUCH WINNING.
I LOOK AT THE NUMBERS.
>> Jesse: TRUMP SAID YOU WOULD
BE SICK OF IT.
>> Juan: IT IS SO
OVERWHELMING, I AM THRILLED.
I UNDERSTAND AS HIS GUEST HE
WILL HAVE STORMY DANIELS MAY BE.
WELL FOR THE PRESIDENT AND DAVOS
COMING IS REALLY IN CHARGE OF
THE SPEECH ALONG WITH STEPHEN
MILLER.
HE LOOK AT THE GUEST LIST,
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE PEOPLE
THERE WHOSE CHILDREN WERE KILLED
BY MS-13.
I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO GO BACK
HARD ON THE IMMIGRATION SIDE OF
IT.
I THINK FROM GARY COHN, YOU WILL
HEAR A LOT OF TALK ABOUT THE
BENEFITS OF ECONOMICS AND THE
TAX CUT AND THE HOPE THAT WHILE
HE TALKED ABOUT AMERICA FIRST,
HE IS NOT SAYING -- I AM
IT'S NOT AMERICA ALONE.
IN THAT SENSE, IT REALLY DOES
SPEAK TO SOMETHING I HOPE HE
DOES WITCHES REACH OUT TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND SAY THAT
THERE IS A POSSIBILITY.
MY FEAR IS THAT'S NOT
DONALD TRUMP.
I CAN DREAM ABOUT IT.
>> Dana: EVEN A YEAR AGO IN
FEBRUARY WHEN HE DID THE JOINT
SESSION SPEECH, KIMBERLY, IT WAS
A TELEPROMPTER SPEECH.
SAID NOW, THAT'S A PRESIDENTIAL
SPEECH.
>> Kimberly: I THINK RESIDENT
TRUMPETS GOING TO EXCEED
EXPECTATIONS TONIGHT.
HE HAS A LOT OF MATERIAL TO WORK
WITH IN TERMS OF ACCOMPLISHMENTS
WITH THE ECONOMY,
INFRASTRUCTURE, TAX REFORM,
IMMIGRATION.
ALL OF THE ABOVE.
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
CHECKPOINTS HE CAN MAKE IN TERMS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY THAT FELT
FORGOTTEN.
I AM HONORING MY PROMISES THAT I
PRESIDENCY.
THE WHOLE THEME OF A SAFE AND
STRONG AMERICA IS ONE THAT
RESONATES.
PROSPEROUS COUNTRY.
>> Dana: ONE OF THE THINGS A
GOOD ECONOMY ALLOWS YOU TO DO IS
HAVE SPACE TO THINK ABOUT OF THE
THINGS YOU WANT TO WORK ON.
PEOPLE ARE FEEL THE ECONOMY IS
BETTER AND CONFIDENCE, HE IS
EXPECTED TO TALK ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE AND OPIATE
ADDICTION IN ADDITION TO
IMMIGRATION.
>> Greg: I DON'T WANT HIM TO
HERE WHAT HE CAN MAKE GOVERNMENT
DO MORE OF.
YOU SHOULD DO A PUNCH LIST, THE
JOBS NUMBERS, THE ECONOMY, HOW
MANY ISIS FIGHTERS WERE KILLED.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED THIS YEAR.
I'M GOING TO TRY AND DO SOME
NOT FOR THE LEFT OF AMERICA.
HE SHOULDN'T CARE ABOUT
IMPRESSING PEOPLE THAT WANT MORE
GOVERNMENT.
HE SHOULD JUST DO IT.
PROVIDER'S PROBLEMS WITH HIM IS
THAT HE'S RUNNING A COUNTRY LIKE
IT'S A BUSINESS.
HE IS LIKE A BOSS AND HE CAN'T
SHAKE IT.
HE SHOULD TREAT IT LIKE A
MEETING, COMES IN AND GOES OKAY,
WE'VE GOT TO DO THIS.
IF YOU WE DON'T DO THIS, YOU ARE
IN TROUBLE.
I AM FIRING THIS GUY.
THAT'S HOW HE TALKS.
HE JUDGES DO THAT.
WAIT USED TO GO, IT DIDN'T
CHOREOGRAPHED AND WE PRETENDED
TO BE INTERESTED.
LET'S JUST LET IT GO.
IT >> Dana: BUT YOU'RE
DEFINITELY GOING TO WATCH?
>> Greg: I HAVE TO.
THE GREAT THING ABOUT TRUMKA A
LOOK AT THE CORRESPONDENTS'
UNDER HIS WATCH.
WHY CAN'T THIS ONE?
DOES THESE BIG, THE POMP AND
CIRCUMSTANCE, THE MAJESTY OF IT
ALL.
TRUMP DOES VERY WELL.
THE DEMOCRATS ON THE OTHER HAND
HAVE I THINK SIX DIFFERENT
RESPONSES TO THE STATE OF THE
UNION.
THEY ARE TOTALLY FRACTURED.
WHO KNOWS WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO
SAY.
PARTY STANDS FOR ANYMORE.
SO I THINK TRUMP WILL RECEIVE A
BIG BUMP AFTER TONIGHT.
>> Dana: THERE WAS A HEADLINE
TODAY THAT SAID DEMOCRATS,
ESPECIALLY IN RED STATES, ARE
STARTING TO PANIC BECAUSE OF ALL
THE GOOD ECONOMIC NEWS.
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK THAT'S
RATIONAL.
ONE OF THE INTERESTING THINGS
ABOUT TRUMP'S POOR POLL NUMBERS
SAY THE ECONOMY IS GOOD.
ECONOMIC CONFIDENCE, CONSUMER
CONFIDENCE UP.
BUT THEY DON'T NECESSARILY
CONNECT THAT TO DONALD TRUMP.
THEY GIVE LOTS OF CREDIT, MORE
CREDIT TO BARACK OBAMA.
AND OBVIOUSLY MOST PRESIDENTS,
WHILE THEY ARE IN OFFICE, THEY
TAKE CREDIT FOR ANYTHING BECAUSE
THEY ALSO GET BLAMED FOR
AMERICAN PEOPLE SAY IT'S
TRUMP COMES IN.
IN RESPONSE TO GREG'S TERRIBLE
ATTITUDE ABOUT OUR WONDERFUL
STATE OF THE UNION ADDRESS, YOU
SO I THINK YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
WHY SHOULD I SHOW UP?
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS -- ONE
OF THE REASONS GREG AND OTHERS
THE STATE OF THE UNION IS
SUPPOSED TO BE JUST A LETTER OR
NOTIFICATION THAT EVERYTHING IS
FINE.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT STUFF.
BUT IT HAS GROWN SO MUCH.
THE VISUALIZATION OF WHO YOU
BRING, IT'S ALMOST BECOME MORE
IMPORTANT THAN THE ACTUAL WORDS
OF THE SPEECH.
TONIGHT BOTH SIDES ARE GOING TO
HAVE VERY COMPELLING AND
INTERESTING MEMBERS OF THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC THERE.
>> Kimberly: IS ALSO A VISUAL
PRESENTATION.
SYMBOLIC IN TERMS OF YOUR PARTY,
YOUR MOVEMENT, THE TYPE OF
THINGS YOU WANT TO ACCOMPLISH.
AND MAYBE SOME OF THE POINTS YOU
WHERE THAT COMMUNITY.
I THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP, BESIDES
HAVING A VISUAL PRESENTATION OF
TERMS OF THE RHETORIC AND
MIRRORING SOME OF THE THEMES HE
LAID OUT IN DAVOS AS WELL
BECAUSE HE DOES HAVE QUITE A BIT
TO WORK WITH.
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP, I DON'T
THINK HE'S GOING TO MISS THE
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT MORE HE
WANTS TO ACCOMPLISH, AND THIS IS
THE WAY IN THE VEHICLE BY WHICH
HE CAN REALLY GARNER THAT
SUPPORT MOVING FORWARD FOR SOME
OF THE LEGISLATIVE POLICIES.
>> Jesse: FOR ALL THE
DEMOCRATS THAT SAY THIS GUYS THE
WORST PRESIDENT OF ALL TIME,
THEY ARE GOING TO BE JUMPING
OVER THEMSELVES TO TRY TO SHAKE
HIS HAND AS HE WALKS DOWN THE
AISLE TO GET A NICE PHOTO
OPPORTUNITY.
>> Juan: DID YOU MISS THE IDEA
THAT PEOPLE AREN'T SHOWING UP TO
PROTEST.
>> Jesse: SOAP TRUMP IS NOT
GOING TO SHAKE ANY DEMOCRATIC
HANDS?
DO YOU WANT TO MAKE A BET?
>> Juan: THE NEWS IS, THEY SAY